these deep green and blue waters were
once the exclusive bathing place of
Georgian Nobles but not anymore
take a dip yourself
[Music]
this great big story is by Georgia
national tourism administration marvel
Canyon is located in the samma gorilla
region of western Georgia the lush
canyons filled with natural waterfalls
and caves that have formed over time by
the flow of the Abacha River the cold
mountain waters have carved a path
through soft limestone to create a
natural wonder which at its lowest level
reveals traces of fossils embedded in
the rock a 40-foot drop from the
waterfall into a pool below
connects the upper and lower parts of
the canyon the pool on the lower level
is known for its cool waters even in the
peak of summer making it the ideal spot
to take in the beauty of nature
visitors are encouraged to take a boat
ride along the water and surround
themselves with the tranquility of the
cascading waterfalls imposing cliffs and
slender moss covered trees magnificent
views can be found either from the water
or the walking trails that crisscross
the canyon via bridges and viewing
platforms
the subtropical climate here influenced
by the moist warm air from the Black Sea
creates a unique ecosystem that allows
flora and fauna to flourish within the
canyon and which is found nowhere else
in the country the sami gorilla region
in which Martin fili Canyon is found now
regarded as the gastronomic hub of the
country was once known as the cultural
center of Georgia the impressive mark
Thule monastery stands on the highest
hill overlooking the village and served
as the center of clerical learning and
administration for centuries and nine
miles to the north in the village of
selkie no Dada dyani dynasty built their
summer retreat acclaimed the Mart viele
Canyon as their personal bathing place
[Music]
it's easy to see why this fairytale
water kingdom with its cool clear pools
and secret waterfalls as enchanted
people's for generations
[Music]
[Music]